back off my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
I could spit into your mouth hello bro
okay now you want me spin your mouth no
I don't want CBD oil you need good luck
I will spit in your mouth it's not good
you rub it into your face that's an
Irish thing dude you don't even know
what's going on Irish dude get your
[ __ ] life together bro my life
together dude yeah there's something
shattered in the other room you see what
that was oh yeah your life dude get a
broom utility room bro get a broom in a
frickin dustpan bro and get your [ __ ]
life together make it up back make an
awesome omelet my umbrella we live right
now we are we're hours on the powers on
man welcome to the king and buzzbuzz
gang gang gang gang gang gang buzz-buzz
dude people a lot of people when I'm out
doing comedy shows will come up and say
um Brandon do they ever yell that what
was it we wish it was Brandon buzz buzz
no I don't get that either
yeah they don't do any of them they're
people bring me honey really people
I'll get honey I'll get weird gifts and
then people because they see the way you
and I interact you know like we bust
each other's balls but we're boys it's
what we do you know they'll come up to
me like man you look like [ __ ] thank you
thank you man oh they're like yeah be
look like sham bro and then him and his
girl like old ladies will start laughing
like oh cool thanks for that thank you
for that get your life together bro or a
guy goes hey nice to meet you man ago
don't [ __ ] touch me like alright man
well they don't want you talking about
and this looks bad right now okay so
please treat me like a human being dang
bro so they're really some people will
they really give you a good let's rip
your drip they'll just rip my tour they
ask me to rip their drip if I do it you
hurt their feelings
yeah we're not feel ballin one guy said
rip my drip and he had a post-nasal drip
actually and he spit in like a little
baggie
I was like ah ha very funny
disgusting disgusting disgusting your
mama came out to you I saw oh yeah my
mom sure you hear from bro
so your mama is a nice center here on
there oh that's a good point actually
muff to put her hair up there a hundred
percent I never want to rip our in to
our moms you know I'm saying but yeah I
saw your mom see I thought no I'm not
even trying to be funny I was like oh
damn that's what Theo gets his hair from
oh yeah she's nice here she got that
silly Nelson bro she got that long you
know she has a very Willie Nelson desk
female vibe yeah for sure you know
strong cover band for Motley Crue oh
yeah cool oh yeah she could hold a rock
over her head for a better part about 40
minutes look at that bro a medium sized
rock with both your mom looks wiry too
Oh bro she could beat my ass bro uh in
the dark yeah and that's a lot of that's
feeling a pretty lady the how old your
monitor she's 72 what's super pretty
plenty - thanks man yeah you know what I
thought it was a couple times this week
and I was like dang mom's pretty hot you
know right yeah I thought I picture my
damn deal finally caught one in the web
that's it knows your mom no oh yeah you
never know the silver here is like in
like Kylie Jenner do it so I didn't know
oh that says Tucson well that's a Tucson
special Tucson but you you know you are
a lot of women instead of wearing those
um you know a lot of women's these days
we'll put a dreamcatcher in their vagina
so they don't have children you know
necks and then they feel incomplete so
it's like it catches the dreams with
that thing called a dreamcatcher
yeah but they call it some different of
a medical term dental dam dental dam no
mm no that's something mom that's just
good that's yeah yeah that's people who
are yeah that's mm-hmm yeah cool oh
thank you man yes you listen to that
Kylie Jenner kind of right a little bit
which is that Tucson sort of like
looking in the desert sort of like catch
a snake in a heartbeat
dehydrated no no I'm saying like in
Tucson you get dehydrated oh yeah yeah
yeah a lot of people you'll find a
kidney stone in his turquoise you know a
guy passed a couple of [ __ ] turquoise
dice right out of his dick mm and that's
Tucson a lot of people go into business
meetings with no shirt sleeves on cut
them off leave them in the car it's that
kind of place did I saw a school bus in
- sometimes somebody had cut the entire
top off that's a party bus and it was
just driving a school bus - getting
three miles to the gallon
hell yeah that's a party bus Oh
yeah and there were some kids on it I
don't know if that was that seemed and
like it I don't know if he knew that and
like the eleventh row there's a couple
kids sitting back yeah forgot to drop
free cut the table but that's Toussaint
man it's that wild place and ice to go
to school up there I was out of Santa
Rita high school
nice watch man really yeah I just
watched Mexican kids fight in the
abandoned car wash well good that was
good it was a like a [ __ ] fighting
really went to Mexican or Duke going at
it it was extreme flyweight you know
that's what I would call it damn home it
was like some of those Rican Roach homes
they bought something one together I was
put on that Lucha Libre mask oh and he
walked over there and everybody beat the
[ __ ] out of him
got it what are you doing sweating if
people are fighting yeah you gotta tie
your [ __ ] mask yeah that's that
dreamcatcher belt man yeah ready to rip
this dripper oh yeah man but you have
people will bring me stuff they'll bring
like a little chunk of cheese for the
RET you know I love it I like a nice
cheddar cheese or they bringing some
[ __ ] Swiss or something no it's
different some guy brought me some gravy
vert I think I'm very very source are
you talking about that's pretty cool for
a rat yes I'm bad oh it's high-end [ __ ]
I like the honey though I want to learn
some cheese oh dude give me drugs so
people bring drugs I don't even a drug
dude yeah yeah you look like a drug dude
do i oh yeah I do I feel like you would
just get like meth or heroin all the
time bro you look you look like the
biggest meth trafficker in [ __ ] San
Jose trafficker no yeah maybe a like a
meth crossing guard I could see that you
know yeah yeah that's cheers I got real
men do that's debt you look a deaf
person doing cheerleading I look like a
manager for the Dodgers
well row let's get him to rip my drip
man because you really Wow am I owe you
a motto you're coming in full Jesse's
smaller today huh Brian can half
yeah bro oh don't be mad but what
happened you hurt your neck this Victor
hit you in the back with the machen bro
I got a new yoga instructor Wow and what
oh my god dude what happened
nope that's just me giving the full
front dog been doing a lot of Delos I
want to see them peaches out the back
some hams out the back bro that piece
looks cobbled bro looks like you got
lucky I already kind of [ __ ] don't be
mad at the kicks either son oh you had a
pet Python as a kid huh huh you know
Python his kid
no but mine's like the type my
neighbor's snake got loose and I and
they found it years later we could hear
it at night and it was huge
always so big man who they're scary
anyway it was hard to sleep with you
when you hear snakes in the wall oh well
my shoes are made of that snake so carry
on oh look at this did you start and
[ __ ] somewhere with a couple of little
people or me eat those looks like I'm
talking [ __ ] to small people yeah it
looks like you're stalking [ __ ] too uh
the people that performed that song all
the small things at the MTV Music Awards
about 20 years ago Wow okay yeah looks
like you went up to Santa's elves and
started [ __ ] selling bad oil to them
dude I'm to get him to put outboard
motor oil into a [ __ ] actual vehicle
or an [ __ ] you're not feeling all
black I feel you you and I we honorable
look at you dude look at that bro what's
up I look like I'm surfing but you look
a hundred percent straight up flex it
can do you like yoga at UH at the at a
correctional is you got there bro take
forever to get there I look like Tony
Hawk's [ __ ] shitty security like I got
a foam on a skateboard no you look like
Timmy penguin bro you don't like Tony
Hawk [ __ ] troubled bird yes and what
are those pants made out of spray-on
licorice did your son paint those on you
this morning check out the peach bottom
baby that's like a team kikiki
that's my [ __ ] dick game rolling out
for her it's all game for you that's
that dark night dick game let me see
what you don't [ __ ] you got hung today
bro give me Theo let me see what deals
rock and we can trip much oh wow look at
him really dressed up today yeah gray on
gray it's not gray
you look like Jesse small let's [ __ ]
event planner this isn't oh yeah creep
dude you look like riff Raff's dumber
brother that went to home scared
first of all Jesse small its event
planner is Frederick David Douglas Duke
bro that's who's playing and yes he's
small as you do right there man I'm
doing drugs and retching yes you don't
have to do a lot of who's like Joe Dirt
live on Broadway finally for only 14
episodes move on you're handsome dude
was tying my shoe that's what I was
doing you I'm not Matt the outfit man
you look like a [ __ ] gym teacher or
whatever that's your vibe you know give
up that vibe like I'm a gym teacher and
I'm just gonna coast through this year I
love those I could see that you look
like a gym teacher like a duties been
teaching a bunch of gyms how to meet
each other in a back alley yeah do this
dude we've got one fan submission for
rip might rip this gentleman holy [ __ ]
man I didn't know that uh a lot to take
you know it's not dude not if you know
that Curt Schilling has spent a lot of
his money on weird stuff and it's it's
crazy to finally see it surmount to this
man jr. Nick Nolte's [ __ ] son that's
Curt Schilling isn't it I thought Nick
Nolte's I stepbrothers know he invested
he rested in a bad video game like I
think where's he yeah there's too much
going out here here's a trick for you
clean the [ __ ] room how about that
you wanna make stuff disappear how about
you a declutter pad oh that guy's a
magician yeah bro there's an opening
David Blaine been raping [ __ ] dude
yeah touching kids as he really uh I
don't know about kids or rape but I know
he's in trouble well I'll say there's an
opening because there's four magicians
in the world yeah that's a good point
and I'll say this man I saw David Blaine
twice at The Comedy Store and each time
no joke he one time he was on a double
bicycle a backstroke
and he had a 19 year old girl in the
back he cocked which is legal it's not
anything crazy but I think he's probably
got 36 or something a little strange
yeah just a little Ricci one time I saw
Matt something you do at home I agree
also don't don't swag on us at the
Comedy Store
yeah tricycle yeah yeah do magic shut
the [ __ ] and a second time he had um he
was on a Vespa scooter and he had a
extremely young woman on the back that's
what he's like exam as being any young
women but I don't know what this is
about it and this isn't PDF Elia I don't
think so this guy's just I think he's
lost I think he bought a [ __ ] magic
kit on the internet and calls himself a
magician now and he's clearly out of his
parents basement and I hope it's going
well for oh this looks like sigur and
Roy's little [ __ ] twink boy whatever
that guy's name is man this guy
describes himself as Hawaiian albino
Chinese and ginger magician now you
white bro you the white magician
so he's [ __ ] chai by no dude yeah I
think people are thirsty man they see an
opening they know David Blaine is being
taken down boom magicians popular
Scottish is what he said white all right
let's move on shut up to that Joe that
does it for rip my dear save that
picture also because that guy anything
could happen with that guy I agree don't
be liable if he freaks out and no just a
lot of kids toys in there like a lot of
he's wearing like a pirate's hat yeah
that's very strange
moving on to current events number one
Martin shkreli also known as the farmer
bro who was sentenced to seven years in
prison in 2018 for fraud has been placed
in solitary confinement for allegedly
running his company via from prison via
a cell phone gangster is it pretty
gangster run a business from your cell
phone in prison but imagine having to
save the charge the whole time because
you go in for six years but you don't
get a charger so you have to really
smoke your smuggle charger in the anus
no yeah you do some pretty strange [ __ ]
for a charger bro yeah you got a trade
like some Scooby Snacks for charges oh
dude you're gonna do some way strange it
for a charger charger you know valuable
a charger is out there dude it took 18
years for what's his name man do you do
frying to get a chest
in order to get a post of a ha but now
into our 19 you have to do you know that
the homies run the train but dude if you
see somebody you know scratching their
ass and the meeting room and they seem
to know they're pulling out at you know
this guy's 100% on his iPhone yeah bring
that magician back up maybe bring that
boy dude [ __ ] t-mobile Thomas up
maybe you can [ __ ] its Nika an iPhone
charger in through
he's got them sticking rings bro you got
those ring Elaine's dude without that
farmer bro kid he he kind of [ __ ] over
the pharmacy agency by getting say HIV
by in those HIV pills remember oh yeah
he wanted them all yeah but then he was
charging the ton form oh you [ __ ]
everybody over oh well they came have
you ever seen a video of them oh yeah
yeah I used to follow me but I even
troll him people hate that dude I
totally bought the wu-tang tape right
they bought the wu-tang I think they
took it from oh yeah dude look I say he
put him in solitary confinement good cuz
I think he seems like an egomaniac so
now he gets exactly what he wants
himself but he's running a company from
[ __ ] solitary confinement yeah yeah I
appreciate the hustle
oh I appreciate the awesome never let
die yeah I just won't stop you know like
you gots to get this business out well
first of all how shitty these prisons
that they're not putting like something
where the people can't use their cell
phones from the prison we gotta hide in
your rectum to call home
yeah dude back in the day you used to
have to put a phone in your rectum keep
it in there you couldn't get out so you
had to sit on it certain ways on the
numbers yet the text miles yeah and next
thing you know bro you try hitting a one
three times in a row next thing you know
you call your mom and then you have to
basically talk down towards your crotch
like a mana seizure yeah they're like
yeah yeah bet on the bet on a bet on
Icarus and race five you know now was it
yeah you got the phone out and about in
your hands is just different yeah so
this guy seemed like that out to prison
I wasn't the one thing in solitary
confinement nobody could really you know
[ __ ] that dude up and every now and then
somebody can't yeah yeah yeah slapped
around a little bit that's what I'm
saying you come home won't you slapped
around a little bit well there's a
bigger sense of humor in the world now
beat
surprised if this man didn't he got the
HIV drug you wanted to keep it all for
himself and raise the prices and what's
something that's easy to contract in
prison the maids they made the wakin ta
boy don't touch me bro [ __ ] touch me
in prison AIDS runs rampant yeah oh dude
they have teams in there they have like
shirts and skins they have shirts and
aids people with you know defendant mm
and if you can't decide what race to go
with yeah you go teammates yeah cuz they
run that [ __ ] they run that boy you
know that's that that's those white
there's white blood count bad boy
yeah you won't be first team all eight
yeah feelin least all-conference they do
dunking when you're so that yeah it's I
think it's it's gonna be interesting
good luck shkreli good luck score Elam's
next up Kellogg is getting out of the
cookie business
they sold brands Keebler Famous Amos and
Girl Scout among others to italian candy
conglomerate Ferraro for 1.3 billion
doing some terrorist [ __ ] are you gonna
give up you know what [ __ ] Girl Scout
cookies I'm sick of them always harass
me by Finn mitts and [ __ ] all the time
how would you make them available all
year it's me the me to movement
why don't Boy Scouts have their own
[ __ ] cookies yeah we're the boys
laying the cookies then chocolate death
oh yeah well look I think you can't have
these girls going door-to-door a lot of
men men sitting at home you know it's
uncomfortable and boys are selling this
now that cheddar corn ain't out a bit
the girls get cookies and the boys get
corn and that's Wisconsin where you
learned that from Wisconsin yeah we
thought we were selling caramel corn
cheese corn you were born as a boy scout
yeah we were house house selling corn I
mean that wasn't I wasn't really a
go-getter with it just sells to a couple
people in his family and their dad you
sold four boxes in seven weeks and three
of them from your mom once too you got
problems here where's the rest of
[ __ ] corn
yeah Nick just says powder all around us
out cheese powder seventeen pounds oh
yeah man I was crazy dude
so that's so Midwest Oh somebody
hustling around cheese corn you that's
as Midwest as he gets [ __ ] popcorn
you ever had a thin man or a tag-along
or a Samoa small I have there we should
count erases yeah thing about it it's
good but I think this I mean I think
that Kellogg's selling the [ __ ] out to
the French bro Farah or are sure I think
it's not those [ __ ] they're
Italian though yeah but you got it bro
but you open those things up it's like a
little patch it's like a bunch of little
Cabbage Patch Kids it's like a bunch of
damn Quidditch balls that's what I feel
like when you get those things you feel
like people should be flying by in the
sky but broomstick it'll taste that good
they're wrapped nicely and don't taste
that good I just don't like how you can
only have them certain time of the year
like we're in America let me have them
whenever the [ __ ] I want also I think
the Girl Scout cookies yeah I'm talking
about them Ferrero Rocher Bowl I don't
know what the [ __ ] those are dude I'm
still caught up on Girl Scout cookie
yeah I don't like outs like North Korea
yeah I agree this one time of year it's
very bait-and-switch
they could have nicotine in them who
know no I don't know what those little
girls are doing their off time with the
[ __ ] cookies well if you're sitting
in little girls to people's house
door-to-door and the same dress thing
yeah preach you know eyes are not like
send nicked with their cookies in that
[ __ ] popcorn yeah the [ __ ] pocket
been a handful of sweaty [ __ ] cheese
curds they're slinging cheese Nick yeah
just slices of cheddar Rosie
how's the house what else we got last
one according to a survey that was
published in The Washington Post
Americans are having less sex than ever
much of it is attributed to young people
especially men under 30 cents to in 2008
men under 30 only 10% of men under 30
we're having not having sex and in 2018
28% of men under the confusing I think
anything about this man no [ __ ] man
no [ __ ] dudes are so stressed to make
money [ __ ] busting nuts bro there's
porno now every device I pick up my
freaking phone right now I got hot
[ __ ] in there that's the nut get to
work yeah five nine to five oh yeah oh
you could get it [ __ ] you could get
some warm [ __ ] out of a Keurig these
days there's suwano everywhere you can't
stay away from it
and I'll say this though that these
fellas what is this about again less
people having sex than ever
underly to you though I don't believe in
Italy I don't trust any of these washing
post any of these CNN news any of these
news remember but I know that is rain
people that said though the election was
going to be eighty percent to twenty
percent all those [ __ ] took an
L all of them had these whatever these
are called
what is it called surveys surveys
they're asking people they want to ask
to get the answers they want I don't
believe this I think is trying to get
young men to think that they're not
having sex are busting nuts no so it'll
be so they'll just want to be just
become consumers if you don't have any
sex drive left you have nothing left
so keep your [ __ ] nuts ripe you know
what I'm saying don't sit on a hot plate
for too long and burn you in burn your
seed down and stay woke bro get out
there and somebody who's willing to [ __ ]
you yeah but not the unwilling yes knock
knock who's there an advertisement hey
deal you like me man you're you're all
over the nation you meet a lot of fans
right oh yeah the one thing I say to all
the dudes you losing your hair get on it
yeah get on it bro sixty-six percent of
men lose their hair by 35
that's our demo bro I know it is get on
those dudes you know what I'm talking
about him mm-hmm the hymns it's not too
late it's easier to keep the hair you
have then replace it you've seen people
that do the hair transplant oh yeah it
was very risky I've seen one of them in
the mirror dude I've had some of the
back put into the front it's exciting
but in the meantime you can hold down
what you have and look good look at
they're all flourishing my brother's
flourishing four hams calm a
one-stop-shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for the pros yep and it
makes you feel good just knowing that
you're taking a step towards preserving
that hair you know like some time you
see a certain animals they got
endangered species bald eagle bald eagle
guess what it could have been just an
eagle and so you got to do hims man and
what I'm talking about is tell you girls
that all the time do you all the time
the bald ones yeah oh it's it's I mean
it's cute but it's it's it's getting old
it's possibly preventable and hims guys
connect you with real doctors medical
great solutions to treat your hair loss
well known generic equivalents to the
name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair there's no waiting room
it's not awkward deal don't worry about
it bro no doctor visits save hours by
going to four hams dot-com it's easy
yeah
you don't to bring in a little you know
put some of your hair in a little bag or
nothing on order now order now our
listeners get a free trial month of
hymns for just $5 today right now while
supplies last
restrictions apply see website for full
details this would cost hundreds if you
went to a doctor pharmacy so right now
go to four hems dot-com slash cats
that's Kate a TS that's right that's
hidden that's fo r hims dot-com / K 80s
for hems comm / cats get that hair Pacey
on Brendan I'll tell you right now deal
I'm getting please don't tell me - I'm
getting thick Oh big boy oh yeah why huh
because anything I want to eat I get in
minutes man is I want a pizza boom
postman what are they doing oh they just
come they come 24/7 I need sushi boom
it's out my door whoa for a sick kid
like me mm-hmm
I take it man oh you're look it's my
personal food delivery system you're
getting thick [ __ ] bro but I dunno I
dunno about post mates man I don't have
to go the store anymore really don't
need it no post mites will deliver
anything I need 24 hours a day 365 days
a year
cuz if you want bro I saw you earlier it
is you laying out of your front yard
with your mouth open
yeah there's coming drop it yeah it's
amazing
anything you're craving post mites can
deliver the the largest on-demand
network in the known universe with more
than 25,000 partner merchants and I know
this actually I'll tell them this for a
limited time post mates Brennan's little
buffet service yeah is giving our
listeners $100 of free delivery credit
for your first 7 days to start your free
delivery download the app right now and
use code K ATS two zero one nine
that's code K ATS two zero one nine for
$100 a free delivery credit for your
first seven days when you download the
post mates app get anything you need
anytime you need it download post mates
and save with code k ATS 2019 gang
may support the podcast and that note
will move it to king it or sting it the
first one comes from Michael snow for
you I saw these products that came out
that is basically a GoPro for your [ __ ]
I think it's called the [ __ ] cam tries
on and you get that [ __ ] I view so King
at our sting it the [ __ ] I view damn I'm
not trying to have a [ __ ] i viewer
things go on huh you know I'm saying
aren't you though you seem like the kind
of guy that would like a [ __ ] ring cam
bro you seem like a goal-line referee at
a gangbang bro definitely just trying to
see if you cross the finish okay I want
my eyes on that lurker dude yeah that
lurker like that pink eye professional
you seem like that real Lert [ __ ] eye
on the submarine bro you know what can
you do it that looks like a real tiny
ring can you do pictures or and doesn't
post to my story what do I do with the
tape what do you do with that what would
you do with that [ __ ] tape what are
you gonna do with that let's say you hit
it from behind you're getting an [ __ ]
30-minute session of just a [ __ ]
think about it that's all you gettin is
an [ __ ] view and people like that
brother that's what I'm here to tell you
release also I want to tell you the has
to do that they have uh it I'm not
carrying what am i now huh
I got a now I gotta carry my penis I has
to carry not only the weight of all the
stress of my [ __ ] work week not only
is it already propped up by six
milligrams of [ __ ] bootleg mm you
know wiener pills them too oh yeah then
real reach or makers run but now I got a
carry a damn camera on it's bad day and
a boom mic yeah whoo my [ __ ] Steven
spiel bus hey how the [ __ ] why do I have
to carry a camera on the back of my
khaki I agree bro
just let me can we live can we bust nuts
do we have to get that close to
everything
dude this is that flow bad enough for
the Sharks yeah that's that uh what does
that camera call do you put on something
small where you can just take off a
GoPro yeah
that [ __ ] bro this is yeah I don't know
what that is dick go
they call it did go that's that blow
project now if you were getting a bj
that's that blow Pro that's what it's
for
bro don't [ __ ] touch me all the time
with touch me but here's the thing now
you have all this video which it could
be anyone though if you're getting up if
you're filming a [ __ ]
you just can two eyes it could be anyone
on now here would be a great thing to do
with this cam would be to put it on a
hot dog at 1:00 in and slowly see
yourself rolling up that thing pretty
quick boy and eating that hot dog keep
throwing the hot dog not deep throating
it enjoying it and having it and having
a meal and then what do you do that
video brawls and it to people that like
to watch people have uh you know good
friends oh we can figure that out but
that's more exciting dude we [ __ ] let's
order one and let's put it on a hot dog
and while these do the hot dogs yeah
let's do on the hot dog let's do on a
bratwurst to just uh thick thick
bratwurst and we're just [ __ ] guys
just lunch man yeah I know but it's
gonna be fun to watch you know what see
look like it's gonna look like a snake
err in Total Recall you remember when he
gets out of the [ __ ] get out of Mars and
he's all that's gonna look good no I was
an infant when Total Recall came out
it's you know dude you're older than me
yeah no I'm not dude that's your
imagination you idiot get a calendar and
yeah that's what's gonna look like me
consuming the hot dogs I'm gonna enjoy
my time that's lowrider boy I'm that
Otis Redding on a Frank Sun is our
Mondale
[Music]
I'll take it easy on a frank about me
often golf that thing but now let's see
what I'm saying don't let it don't let
him sentence us to some sexual [ __ ]
let's find unique ways to youth that use
things eat a banana bro hey eat a banana
with your buddy you know yeah you both
film it man Oh bro I'd love to watch
somebody some bad girl get potassium
dumped more than I would another bang
session that I can find anywhere else
maybe you can get two for one cameras
you can put two cameras on a banana have
your girl tried deep till both of them
really let's see how many she can do to
how many cameras you can take how many
bananas she can take yeah I guess you
can I get weird about it bro
yeah or you have a contest with your
chick or have your girl enjoy some
breakfast and make it calm brother yeah
look at that now think of a camera on
the end of that do put your boner way
there you put the camera on the end of
that who is Jesse Smollett Jesse
Smollett should open up a juice bar
that's not a bad idea
all right next Oh King understand it is
a bad idea dude let's keep going
I will I'm gonna King [ __ ] [ __ ] cams
cuz I like the idea put on bratwurst
eNOS okay darlin I'll king him that way
man I'll King on there I'm not trying to
see your girl's [ __ ] well I just
think you know we got enough sexual
ization malice but listen let's rethink
we ways that we could use stuff that
could be enjoyable what's used
technology for more than just sex
yeah lay off that [ __ ] Knology bro dude
get on yourself a 6-inch sub a meatball
sub put a camera on the end and [ __ ]
[ __ ] it I wish we have one on the
end of Jesse small it's a little 6 inch
or that he bought dude see [ __ ]
[ __ ] key yeah
all right never own brother next up from
Andrew Middleton gang baby
interesting a hot guy country shut up to
that dude he said dating a co-worker now
first of all he looks like a
wall-to-wall trucker whatever it is you
know what is that called
do you just mean a truck driver driver
yeah so if he a co-worker you don't have
a co-worker something and he's thinking
kidnappee mm that or yeah he's either in
kidnap his manager who he calls and gets
the route from that's true or is even
pick up a lot lizard now that would be a
co-worker you can't really defend you
can't talk about yeah well we have truck
drivers here we have the soda ban your
point Namor's back could be yeah respect
another now there's subcontracted
they're not under employment of the
actual truck okay so it's not a real
co-worker so a co-worker would be what
uh your driving partner which is
typically another do is it really maybes
into that right maybe you want to sleep
you know for 12 hours while those you
drive oh yeah or maybe want to drive a
mr. Darren do what's the thing called
everyone get busy when he park was
dating a co-worker King at are stinging
dude well I don't know about truck
driving but if you're in a normal office
where else you gonna meet people hate
how they always ban [ __ ] like in the NFL
or in the UFC can't date the ring card
girls what the [ __ ] am I supposed to do
yeah where where am I gonna meet someone
she's hot as [ __ ] I'm here she's how
about to Urijah Faber dude he [ __ ]
won't tell him that bro
yeah you can't tell anyone tell anyone
that
no dude everybody's dating the ring card
girls man you know you know mine so
dating a co-worker like if you're in the
office you know I'm saying like you're
in office and there's some bad secretary
who's just like looking up and down why
not yeah I remember I used to wash
dishes dude if you [ __ ] any waitress
you were like the King yeah when you
were the dishwasher dude cuz you had to
go you had to like I mean you had to
read no class oh yeah it's a really
hustle oh um yes it's a game and there
was always that one girl she dyed her
hair purple every now and then and she's
going through some tough stuff it's
super boyfriend cheated on her yeah
there you are washing dishes all wet and
[ __ ]
making $7 an hour and you had no pick-up
line so I'll just spray or with that hot
water gun which you come in the back
yeah and get that sponge neck and
washing my body when she'd come back
there [ __ ] yeah
but dude yeah I think so you got to have
a chance to date a co-worker's nothing
wrong with it there's still a there a
human being they're human rules apply
don't rape anybody and don't be a
straight-up you know too much of a
lurker brah
but also dude you don't have to [ __ ] on
the job yes they can [ __ ] off hours yeah
[ __ ] somewhere else yeah I King it okay
the truck driver seems a little strange
or whatever yeah next one for King er
sting it from Ray Martinez okay let's
see ray boys CEO Brenda showers that's
all Brendon I was in New Mexico couple
months ago Bryan Callen he gives you all
your deal but anyways King listing it
I don't braces thinking about getting on
that it's like you're getting us a too
late you know
just early enough oh man buzz buzz buzz
brother were you out on adult braces
look man I like it I think it reminds
you of what it's like to be a child you
know get a little peace I like to do
childish stuff as an adult you know get
you a um like weird child clothes yeah
nothing too small but yeah I'll wear
like a you know a turtleneck with like
my name on the back of it every now and
then like that I had as a child I'll you
know get a um little truck I had as a
child and you know play with it for a
minute or you know or do this do you buy
a coloring book and just [ __ ] your pants
on Monday night what I don't relate to
you dude I'm not like a method actor I
don't know about having something nice
you know maybe look at some old photos
or so oh you know or do something like
that get children's braces as an adult
and that's a thing also at that point
you're kind of a lab animal you look
more like an experimental human if you
have a braces as an adult it look like
things aren't going well if you're 44
knee out braces like why not get the
[ __ ] Invisalign yeah are you getting
the full metals yeah why going metals
but metals are reliable they're
trustworthy and you're also keeping the
steel industry in business maybe we're
doing Invisalign that's when a lot of
people's families went out of business
and some of these you know in Buffalo
and in Pittsburgh steel yeah you gotta
think about even a small scale everyone
they're like little train tracks on your
teeth and you were a tough person yet to
carry you know two ounces of steel and
you [ __ ] and you yepper you know
nowadays Yona round plastic dude they're
doing braces through the mail now yeah
you should show them a picture of you
smiling they send your mouth yeah and
probably here's the thing if you buy
braces through the mail you're a [ __ ]
idiot problem bonafide you're gonna do
braces through the mail how about what
about this colonoscopy we do [ __ ] via
email
you know you out of your mind you can't
fix your teeth through the mail
no but here's the thing do you trust
anyone who's gone through life at 46
years old at 46 men you know what I want
to fix my teeth oh yeah I do cuz it's a
little strange to me like just Rock the
[ __ ] up teeth that might be your
personality well some people they want
nobody wants to be a real grill Rilla I
think I get it now there's some style to
it but if you out there monkey swag to
it though when you got that one cut kind
of hitter just sticking out the side
yeah but if your monkey and around in
your own enamel gym brother that [ __ ]
ain't [ __ ] legitimate dude a lot of
them are like I used to have a lot of
spaced out teeth and I wish I still had
them sometimes it's nice that one yeah I
feel like it'd bring more flavor to you
I had large spaces me not what I didn't
like was you would lose a food you would
lose you'd be talking to somebody in a
you know look piece of salmon or
something you had that hippo structure
teeth yeah you just you get that you
know you got options for food to leave
your mouth now what could you do for
your teeth
I got bra what did I do I got Invisalign
man no yeah because I when I was young
some of my siblings I could get the Mack
I could get the braces or I could get
some turbo genes when I was young you
know talkin geneco's no turbos Brian I
chose them [ __ ] Brian I look fly as
[ __ ] yeah a war than [ __ ] nine days a
week son they were nice to African cuts
Babu
I don't know Jumbo's I know I know bro
you're Bo jeans daddy French dry and
this before we sold America to Ferrero
rocher's bruh [ __ ] down get them headers
brah Lincoln think click on them house
son
that's them right there yeah I mean
that's a real urban version give me some
basic but
man right there no right there in the
middle boom they were a bad girl huh
there you go zoom in on that cat turbos
see the crotch had a little bit of
writing on it so people had to read by
your crotch and you had a chance at
opportunity for you dick
different times boy Mowrey Francois did
you ever seen the lucky jeans when he
unzip it says lucky you feel he said me
to movement where'd it happen
that's Irish man mmm I'm not familiar
those jeans
I know I know geneco's you guys remember
geneco's in here your bows were Elsie
not homeschool Joe's gutter bra Jing
COEs meant you were gonna you know that
was people you know it was a lot of
people it did spray paint and [ __ ] like
that
that's true your bows were really good
wearing the church gremlin your bow
sounds fancy they were nice man but it's
French I'm you know the only one II had
a lot of French stuff well that makes
sense yeah you have French stuff
crescent rolls your bow jeans you know
you had some [ __ ] shitty hats what
else we got heartless rock was it was
that was it we're we on rip my drip with
the [ __ ] understand adult braces if
you need them sure so I'll King it yeah
but also its its base like buying a
[ __ ] convertible yellow Corvette some
midlife crisis first of all just rock
your [ __ ] teeth I like them King it I
like him it's your personal choice last
one from kinder seeing it from a man
j-rod
[Music]
[Music]
69 your clone for a million Wow you
would do it you would definitely do it
no you it would - you know both you have
low sex drive so I feel like you and
your partner just fall asleep you just
talk about mass sleep do we get a couple
hundred bucks for just discussing in
laying there next to each other I
I'm confused though - who gets the
million dollars meter the clone he's
still living do we split it cuz that's
only 500k I think sucking dick for 500k
a mil okay and he's awesome but do you
have to put body in your own mouth and
you're not controlling it bro that's
crazy you know well you know what you
but you know yourself like he's not
gonna freak out you know you know what's
going on you don't know what your clones
doing what if he's doing cloned oh poor
[ __ ] clone code bro yeah that's good
point maybe dive into the same stuff
yeah bro that's crazy you have to go to
his place we have to come to your place
there's too many variables I probably I
but it's gonna be a hard pass for me
really yeah I'm gonna say sting that mil
yeah I'm gonna say sting and I'm all set
bro really yeah so you got to hook up
with your clone 69 and is your Colombian
out of actual human cells or is it like
more like plastic you think or
fiberglass like one of those vegan
burgers is there but also can the is the
clone like is it a transgender version
of me or is it just it's just like me
it's a [ __ ] boy he's the - [ __ ] boys go
ahead you're a [ __ ] or we bout to be
some [ __ ] boys or is it a transgender
be shop you know like a like a like a
[ __ ] Bruce Jenner style you know what
say you're looking at guy who only
delivers boxes to Claire's boutique dude
that's the [ __ ] you look like and also
would you do it huh would you do it
there's so much going on there me you
would really have an opportunity to get
to know yourself do you get to ask your
clone any question no man you just hit
it and quit it and he's on his [ __ ]
way with 500k he's like later nerd and
where's he taking it
now if it's your clone
baby's not sober he's gonna spend on
[ __ ] [ __ ] and drugs yeah I guess I
would do it just because I would want to
be you know trying to help my clone out
if he's going through a tough time you
might need the money talking right yeah
I can't get damn he gave me an easy on
that I was joking well no you got me on
the help of the mouth what's my clothes
like down and out bro you think I really
knew this my life suck you're dead yeah
well blowing himself and gonna help him
dude I sting it no King it Wow all right
that does it for a king understand it
let's move on and help some people with
relationship advice the show girl named
Stephanie called from Boston
Massachusetts Cole didn't get to make
your show Theo but another time now
please it's have a chip advice my girl
well my exhale we broke up she she left
me for someone else
she's calling back like two months later
saying she made a mistake saying she
loves me saying that she wants me back
can she do anything so uh I'm kind of
stuck because she really hurt me but I
really was in love with this girl so
much she's really hurt about give her a
second chance so yeah I'm kind of stuck
see if you guys who caught me out I love
you both so much you guys make me laugh
in the darkest of places for real like
keep doing you guys because you're
helping a lot of people whether you
recognize it or not I love you both and
uh you guys have a good day wait
dang love you Stephanie Bow Wow very
sweet message thank you for that uh for
the kind words you seem like a nice
young lady it's nice that you care
enough about yourself to think about
this I think you know like have you ever
had that like oh yeah and I gave in and
I went back with them and I always kind
of you lose for me anyway
I lost a little bit of like integrity
kind of a little bit cuz it was tough to
kind of stand your ground yeah that
makes sense
but also sometimes I'm not defend what
that lady did but maybe she didn't
realize what she had won out and was
like oh it's better on this side of the
grass went out there's like actually
she's dope oh I'm never doing that again
right then went back was like I'm never
doing I'm in I'm in hundred-percent yeah
so it's either be dope but it's gonna
have to be on stead
me where she can't get over the fact
that she stepped out on her that's it if
you can't get over that it's never gonna
work that's true if you can't get all
that then yous gonna be holding that
against her the whole time yeah it's not
gonna no you're just gonna be pinning a
fricken you know the trauma on that
donkey constantly yeah so if you can't
if you're never you're gonna have to net
you can't mention it again you're gonna
have to forgive her and then you just
should definitely talk about it though
yeah right away
ear it out and move the [ __ ] down but if
you can't move on go somewhere else yeah
if you can't move on then just take more
time and then maybe try it again later
on when things aren't as fresh two
months think things can still be a
little bit fresh true shout out to
Stephanie though yeah good luck but it
seemed like you have a very the ability
to love others pretty easily and
agreeing that you value that so you know
I said give it a try if you can get over
it yeah I say give it a try if you can
get everyone makes mistakes everybody
makes mistakes that's true so and yet I
try to communicate as clearly as you can
and if it doesn't work out that's okay
this you tried alright the next one
comes from Savannah when your best
friend is in love with you but you are
sexually attracted to them at all what
do I do
did we try do we not I help me out it's
your best friend like a warlock but
here's the thing here is eventually
there's someone out there who's jay-z
sick of [ __ ] Beyonce so eventually
you just hang out with your best friend
so you can come a time down the
relationship when you're so used to each
other you could be dating [ __ ]
Jessica Simpson or prime Carmen Electra
and their prime and eventually yeah
that's vanilla ice cream video you're
used to it all day so it's your best
friend you guys vibe a little bit might
as well try it cuz everyone that that's
what it turns into if you don't marry
your best friend you [ __ ] yeah you
know what they say boy don't come on my
back and tell me it's raining daddy yeah
you're right and I'll say this that uh
truthfully asking she wanted to know if
she should date her desk best friend
even though she's not sexually attracted
have to see the friend though too like
if he's like super busted some things
you just can't get over will see you
dating him if you're not attracted I
mean I think there's if this.value and
having like a relationship sometimes
where sex is and the main thing
sometimes people go for sex is the main
thing and the odds of that working out I
don't think are that great no I think
you can have a great relationship with
somebody you know and maybe you you guys
get a little bit of sex here and a
little bit of sex there you know
some door-to-door sex but I don't think
that um I don't think you should just
have to have sex with somebody just
because you know they want to kind of
and you're just kind of on the fence
about it but you could also always try
it you could try giving each other a
little handbag maybe it's a real table
count in the sack though maybe looks
like [ __ ] but in that sack that [ __ ]
shitty caterpillar grows wings and just
[ __ ] starts our pomp turns into a
real [ __ ] Falcon yeah you know real [ __ ]
fly so yeah if you guys are already
really close I think as long as you try
and communicate during it you can be
like oh this is work and this isn't
working
and then just figure it out as you go
sometime could it be a [ __ ] yell or
doing or you know masturbating somewhere
indoors or outdoors yeah using your feet
get weird
oh yeah Buffy the [ __ ] fly if it does
happen be buddies man yeah beep [ __ ]
flies what else we got that does it for
relationship advice and just a reminder
we want to solve your problems so send
in those video questions for
relationship advice people are sending
in text we need video questions we need
the video y'all's video it's teamwork we
put out video when you put in video when
we put out your video or that's the
dream work yeah teamwork makes the cream
work - yeah don't we get me who say
cream though I didn't wait you do I took
my eye all right what else we got next
up I'm [ __ ] we get me bro is debate
club and the first ones coming all the
way from Glasgow Glasgow Scotland oh
[ __ ] you
from Wade oh don't you know I would have
do what up Brendan so Brad King bee
sting coming to you live from right in
the middle of Louisville and Nashville
you know Scotland Kentucky follow up in
this quick debate club taking him back
to when I was 12 years old you know what
I'm talking about
oh yeah Faith Hill hmm nurses should not
yet a bus and nuts to these girls for
the gang Skeet Skeet Skeet Skeet baby
show voice thank you player thanks guys
Scotland apparently that guy bought a
bad map when he was young yeah oh I'll
take kick turn
stomp stomp I'll take that Shania Twain
all day boy feel like the woman oh oh oh
any crazy do what I bear sure it's good
[Music]
listen I'm also God Faith Hill is
looking drippy drippy there oh the
paycheck we got Faith Hill all goddamn
day Shania Twain know when her heyday
and shi'ites now as far as musically
Shania Twain all goddamn day she has two
hits but Faith Hill can [ __ ] get
Faith Hill for me bro
yeah faith a little more you know done
up and done out you know and she also
has Tim McGraw so if you're getting if
you're making love to Tim McGraw you're
gonna be able to sing you done it right
yeah you do to songbirds
yeah dude look I'll tell you this at
Bubba Sparxxx [ __ ] bus on my back I'm
gonna be able to [ __ ] drop a few bars
myself you know anything I'm gonna be
that stands a bad boy so what I'll say
this Oh Shania Twain did it at a time
she's a brunette that did a lot of
blondes can do it they do it blondes
blondes
it's easier you got a feel diner here
but yeah I hear you yeah and Shinya did
it straight out of the gate and she's
like 40 percent Native American oh wow
or she's in Narcotics Anonymous I'm not
sure but there's an NA next to her name
I know I've seen in different articles
and I'll say this man Shania as far as a
hit X to that no yeah Faith Hill that
must be six seven then I'm going Faith
Hill what's the book what's the vote
yeah let's see what the bow that with
the audience
Shania 20 wagering stop stall I don't
know about one bro I know so in a boots
and amort in a beginning in the box
Oh totally crazy do you wanna do short
skirt oh oh
working at Friendly's we you will love
my smile know what else we got next up
from Haley are Oh Haley R what's up bee
sting in the rat cage Haley from Iowa
and I've got a debate for you but you
don't have a girl with nasty teeth or
bad acne you don't have either girl yeah
nice teeth and good skin here's here's a
theory I grew up with around the gym
yeah is whenever you saw a girl with
acne that meant to her home horns were
off like she was all crazy cuz she had
acne she was down the [ __ ] she was a
frisky type brilliant yeah it was the
word on the street girl to acne she was
down well a lot of girls to got her
early on that creatine may be no more
than a roids yeah yeah yeah I said date
a girl one of my first girlfriends was
doing I think deca 200 or something she
would lift me up after school
yeah and hold me like that and carry you
home no just talking a little bit but it
was it was it was tough it was kind of
nice though it was nice a yeah yeah she
was cool she was strong she was cool but
I'll say this what was the question
again man saved her acne bro
Oh teeth or acne I'll go with either one
you know I've had both growing up I
don't mind you know I remember this one
girl we both had acne and we'd get so
nervous when getting here to kiss each
other our pimples will just literally
bust on each other [ __ ] pepperoni
pizza it was sexy as [ __ ] dude John yeah
when somebody girl I got this big a
white head yeah and it just busts cuz
you're just so much friction ah
disgusting oh dude look
Sbarro's [ __ ] pizza I thought it was
cool man I thought it pretty cool and
it's young when you're that age to just
even have that much sebum flying out of
your body naturally a lot of fluids
flying very beautiful man yeah you're
like a little [ __ ] Old Faithful um so
it's [ __ ] up teeth are bad acne [ __ ]
man sometimes teeth brings character you
know if you got them them [ __ ] up
teeth I'm gonna go yeah I would go I
would say this with teeth you can get
lip extensions you can get you know a
mouthpiece be a queer mouthpiece you
could wear fake teeth now they have the
right Halloween yeah so I think there's
different all the types of cure Ken
there's got them craters you just roll
in to work with the craters well dude
skin is the Lord's textile Ron you gotta
pray you know to get you got to pray it
away sometimes thanks god damn this you
know do it it is yeah if you draw some
red dots them sometimes he does I mean
you're so full of that fire yeah I'm
gonna go with I'd rather have a girl
with [ __ ] up teeth yeah I'd rather
probably have that grill a real grill a
little baby grill reloj people would
rather have bad acne Wow 70% Jesus what
we're having a girl as well as the
question yeah all right stud last one
for debate club comes from Nick dope
name right don't Nick Brannen showers
Theodor Van Winkle
sup guys so names Nick coming at you
from coming Georgia yeah the name I City
coming Georgia with both Bell vo I would
recommend you not show up here cuz I
think just seeing the street signs would
probably just set you off but anyway
guys for one happy late birthday to both
of y'all hope they were great I got a
debate club for you since y'all hit-the
hit-the Georgia home town y'all went to
chick-fil-a over in and out I got a ask
the the breakfast side of it now y'all
go in Waffle House or IHOP
obviously we're leaving Deniz out of
this because Deniz is just complete
horseshit so laughs house I hop that's
your debate gang gang buzz-buzz
you guys come down to Atlanta sometime
soon guarantee you'll have at least like
five people in the crowd and it's
probably gonna be me with my friends so
I love you guys take care
yang Brooke Skeet Skeet brother that's a
coming country bro yeah Doug high school
team mascot is the bus it's the bus just
a big ol [ __ ] eggplant oh and their
roar shocker
circus ah as far as the [ __ ] I hop
remember I hope their whole campaign
when they try seeing the International
House of burgers yeah and when they did
that [ __ ] I think it's like such
backlash like I'll [ __ ] it sting it
we're gonna stick with pancakes yeah
[ __ ] I hop Waffle House all day I like I
like the Waffle House I don't never know
what to expect man it's you rolling the
dice rolling you go in there you might
get shanked oh yeah it might meet a
friend might meet a girl you might get
beat up in the parking lot oh yeah I
like that
well there's a lot of racial violence to
it a lot of these places late at night
you know you could see it a constantly
you know there's a lot of and you know
and different people fight in different
places and you see a lot of black people
fighting at UH at Denny's in the middle
of the night or Waffle House you've seen
anyone get beat up at IHOP never [ __ ]
yeah that's Joe I'm saying like I hope
for a little more like the suburbs yeah
safe yeah though talk [ __ ] they're like
tweet and they're like fun to sue you
and give you a bad yelp review
I like the the risk of a shank at the
waffle Oh waffles is [ __ ] the you
know it's breakfast UFC right over there
but you'll see people going at it yeah
see somebody beatin each that's our left
hook and a [ __ ] waffle for a side of
eggs bro catching a [ __ ] yolk to the
dome very risque in fact people are
constantly sending me links of people
getting murdered and beaten at a Denny's
and and different breakfast places are
interesting you know at this point you
almost want to switch to lunch to say
[ __ ] breakfast if it's that day that's
what I say just for everyone should fast
it's a dangerous game baking just you
want a breakfast versus how bad you want
it bro but otherwise wall files all day
man Waldo's dude I remember I went into
a wall house one time actually when I
was on
and drugs and try to get people to sign
up for a softball team to play against
another late a huddle house across town
and onside I [ __ ] some got [ __ ]
punch me yeah you're damn right he did I
was trying to sign up for a goddamn
softball team while they're at breakfast
I had three people signed up and they
had a big brother that was working on
the grill and I kept trying to recruit
him oh I say you could hit Homer you be
the Frank Thomas bro
he'd give me the big herd over here he
don't want to hear it and he got fired
three times while I was in there cuz the
grill guy always gets fired and it comes
back they'll go back out they have to
have you got like the quarterback Bo if
you can't fire the quarterback right you
back you're fired back yeah yeah oh dude
that's Ryan Leaf on them [ __ ] uh
McGriddle so they got it you know you
got to really have somebody in there
look at the fan saying dude I saw a guy
grill up a couple quaaludes right there
just grill up a couple of uh might as
well oh yeah grill up a couple things of
fentanyl right there on the grill pretty
beautiful hot fentanyl's - fifty-five
percent of the oh yes they waffle house
well played wolf house the cheese is
better the eggs and cheese and they have
raisin bread yes and they have class all
right well that does it for debate club
moving on to the last segment of the day
flaunt my aunt of my a boy and the first
one was submitted from Benjamin off of
Snoop Dogg's Instagram this is aunt
uncle Jerry oh God diggity dog you know
no background culture vulture right
there no background on him Dee there's
no info this guy's like every part of a
of a funeral is that Johnny Depp that's
[ __ ] Johnny diphtheria dude this guy
seems like he definitely needs to have
some tests on medically yeah he does not
look all there look at his nails and the
cockatiel out the front I bet you that
dude has a couple [ __ ] cams oh he's got
that I put some [ __ ] filters on him
and [ __ ] yeah the Tim Burton filter oh
yeah he's got that uh he also has that
on yep that Nightmare Before Christmas
vibe that's what's going on there oh and
he gots that New Year's weave - can we
go back
oh [ __ ] he gets that New Year's wee boy
he's got that a sugar rape on zl-- damn
he's like Jeff Foxworthy oh yeah Jeff
Foxworthy made every bad choice in his
life it looks like Jeff qui Shafak
swarthy dude
well here's I'm saying is he has what is
predominantly you know regarded as an
urban style female haircut polka
something you would see in a you Honus
burg or in Cape Town you guys how long
song just stands in out of his don't
also get your flat tips out of my face
to anyone trying to see that bro put a
little more effort into it if you're
gonna do it
I just don't pass on that [ __ ] bikini
and then get a weave and I think you're
all sexy and [ __ ] get your nails done I
agree tits done bro is it being a BOCES
go extra with it yeah he seemed like a
UH like a thought at Edgar Allan Poe
memorial so it looks like you mr. steel
your man too if you got the right kind
of man you know did he look trust him
mr. steel your mayonnaise dude he looks
like a basketball wife but for one of
the Charlotte Bobcats do more than
[ __ ] or for one of the Phoenix Suns
of eleven wins this year like the know
scared of Love & Hip Hop New Orleans
yeah do ya Love & Hip Hop junior high
school and Edgar Allan Poe elementary
can we zoom in on his tattoo yeah what's
this - got that upper tip tab you got
that one buys cockatiel - like a
stripper going on it
look at the hand tattoos look like he's
trying to be cardi B yeah what does that
say we don't know know who knows maybe
it's bright I mean in English we got
nothing yeah so this guy go to school
how does hope he's an organ donor do cuz
I don't know if he contributed much but
at the same time beautiful young you
know middle-aged kind of her older guy
he's experiment he's doing things he
wants to do this unique he's living this
truth now I think you should a little
more effort into it but living this
truth whatever that is and good luck on
this season of real love and hip hop
yeah dude yeah all right next up sent in
by Stephen this is his aunt
Suzanne no it's just like a Halloween
pic or was she trying to look like
[ __ ] Ozzy Osbourne all we know is
she's from Toledo well that's the Rust
Belt too and she looks like she could
use a couple tetanus shots man because
she if you don't get it acclimated to
the rust man you [ __ ] a [ __ ] idiot
your brain yes you might have Mercer
going on ursa cheese tart Leigh yeah
Alice Cooper all day yeah very Alice
Cooper very Charles Manson very Charles
Manson very [ __ ] just Gough as it
gets and that just like she runs the
book club for the goth kids kind of cook
but she has I love her hair she is very
much like a Geena Davis sort of I'm I
feel like I've never seen Geena Davis in
that light ever really nope nope nope
don't know Bell yeah Gina Davis Marilyn
Manson vibe I'd say okay I would say
that a little bit she has a little bit
of Geena Davis though hmm
do you know if it's in this you talk
about the beetlejuice no this is Geena
Davis she's a Beetlejuice bro she was
yeah Wow Ursa buff Geena Davis out there
that's talking up these Google damn
she's all alone at the buffet bro yeah
ah damn [ __ ] all the roids yeah wow so
yeah definitely a beautiful aunt she
seems like a wild western she seemed
like she could be seems like she might
put a spell on you oh she's a [ __ ]
Toledo [ __ ] a toledo toledo nine
right there boy could be magician and i
don't know
yeah but if it's your aunt i dig her
yeah don't put up spelling i don't know
if she's up she could be a tradition too
but
I don't know if she's doing magic but
she's [ __ ] doing tragic boy there's
because she's doing Satan's work oh yeah
she looks like she could [ __ ] juggle
somebody's you know a couple of spleens
in a jar gallon jug a couple lives what
else you got
last one for flop my aunt this was sent
in from Montana from Ben and this maybe
soon-to-be his odd it's his uncle's
girlfriend Tammy was that Roseanne oh
damn damn she's posted up she's driving
that hog she's trying too hard get her
yeah this is planking him in Montana
yeah she's obviously you know one of
Hells Angels and she does that looks
more like a Mongol to me really yeah I
like that oh is that zip up in the front
mm-hmm got the bandana on the leather
gloves gonna show pretty eyes got little
bit of blonde hair like to see the hog
though and I'm talking about a bike sure
you are dude I'd like to see that long
[ __ ] that long clam she's probably
spotting you know and I say this brush
she seemed like the kind of girl uh she
seemed like the kind of girl that will
thumb wrestle a [ __ ] uh a Willer you
know yeah she could be a truck driver
job she looketh kennel ad he could drink
some real hot water fast you know or oil
fearless yeah or motor
she probably has an outboard you know
four-stroke heart you know she looks
like the one who's shotgunning beer at
every party oh dude she could grill
probably I bet if you put two um she
looks like your favorite restaurant is
the sizzler yeah she look like she could
grill someone or one of her arms yeah
shut up to that end yeah shout out
beautiful Eddie Tammy's her name yeah oh
yeah very well I get Roseanne vibes like
if Roseanne was in a biker gang mm-hmm
like if Roseanne was in Sons of Anarchy
I like it beautiful
that does it for flaunt my aunt got
there damn these odds be killing it was
my mom have more sisters man I know man
well my dad has a 14 brother and sister
so yeah yeah we'll see that's it that's
their brother well we did it huh we did
it man another one congratulations man
congrats to you bro
see you this week - man we're off - nice
to feel like we're always we only see
each other here now just on Tuesdays we
see each other so busy I don't even know
right now we got on I don't know what
country I'm in yeah I don't know man I'm
going on in Kansas City and and that's a
week yeah um you were just in Phoenix
right yeah that's all that's coming up
right now I'm at Phoenix end of the
month well into the month brother yeah
man I'm sure a lot of people come out
give you some money yeah one of mine
buzz-buzz come out Gang Gang man we'll
see you guys next all right lover guy
apiece you man take care
[Music]